this July have your voice be heard hi
first I purged show your support I've
heard because it's my civic duty for the
purge i purge because staying in is an
American this is your emergency
broadcast system announcing the
commencement of the annual purge the
soul of our country is at stake the
center is going to win you show it to
mcgrill changes the purge has to come to
an end at the siren all crime including
murder will be legal for 12 hours
senator let's begin lockdown all
emergency services will be suspended
your government thanks you for your
participation we're going to use this
year's purge to do something about that
senator we're being at it
go go go we are on a roll how's that kid
- this what are you doing outside on
purge night senator come with us there
are threats everywhere with death
everywhere
y'all need to see this
being one goal survival
come
run I purged to keep my country great we
played a lot of purge James's heaving we
have just one more
it's called mommy's choice which one of
you will survive this year's purge the
soul of our country is at
the purge targets the poor and the
innocent the center is going to win
going to mcgrill changes to it is a
night that is defining our country it's
time to do something about that senator
the purge has to come to an end you take
a lot of risks senator I have to I was
the only one of my family to survive
want me to apply for this position I
almost did something unfortunate Sanders
back I want this night card I want that
in all these rooms we got eyes and ears
on everything all right let's begin this
is your emergency broadcast system
announcing the commencement of the
annual purge at the siren all crime
including murder will be legal for 12
hours your government thanks you for
your participation
someone betrayed us this is not a drill
we are on our own they were going right
now survival
senator come with us German
understanding sense thank you it is our
duty to help protect her here they come
bless of the America for letting us
purge and cleanse our souls join me as
we eliminate
this July have your voice be heard
hi parts I purged I purged I purged I
purged because staying in is in America
don't let your freedoms get taken away I
purged because it's my civic duty show
your support I purged for my family for
the purge I purged to keep my country
great the purge election year we played
a lot of purge games to see bigger we
have just one more
it's called mommy's choice which one of
you will survive this year's earth the
soul of our country is at
the purge targets the poor and the
innocent the center is going to win
joints mcgrill changes to it is a night
that is defining our country it's time
to do something about that senator the
purge has to come to an end you take a
lot of risks senator I have to I was the
only one in my family to survive
what made you apply for this position I
almost did something encouraged nights
and years back I want this night car I
want men in all these rooms we got eyes
and ears on everything all right let's
begin this is your emergency broadcast
system announcing the commencement of
the annual purge at the siren all crime
including murder will be legal for 12
hours your government thanks you for
your participation
someone betrayed us this is not a drill
we are on a roll
we're going right now survival senator
come with us
Jenna understand what's at stake
it is our duty to help protect her here
they come
bless of the America for letting us
purge and cleanse our souls join me as
we eliminate evil
yes it's that time of year again folks
when society calls on us to play our
part in the annual purge but one night
only all crime will be legal
airports across America were buzzing
today as hordes of international
travelers arrived in the country to take
part in the annual purge if the ultimate
freedom
Sippi called murder tourists as
America's annual night of legal crime
takes on a global dimension for the
first time it experienced go forward but
as the countdown to this year's purge
continue my campaign that threatens to
end the event for good is gaining
momentum opposition senator Charlie
Rowan has outraged traditionalists by
calling for an outright ban on all
projective it it is a night that is
defining our country the purge has to
come to an end and as the most divisive
purge night in history approaches many
fear for the safety of this
controversial senator it's time to do
something about that senator all right
let's begin
amendment of the annual purge at the
siren all crime including murder will be
legal for 12 hours the only way that I
can win is to risk everything my job is
to eliminate risks and keep you alive we
are going to use this year's purge to do
some spring cleaning someone betrayed us
it's coming for you we are on our own
they want you dead senator there's a
whole world of crazy out there
it's me and one going right now survival
what are you doing outside on purge
night senator may I send an
assassination attempt morph you tracking
us everybody
I need to make sure you get through this
night purging is the American Way the
soul of our country is at stake the
purge targets the poor and the innocent
the sin is going to win
it's going to make real changes to it is
a night that is